well Andrew Tate joins me again now
Andrew good to see you salaam alaikum
peers good to see you I I've genuinely
been Amazed by the reaction I've had in
the streets not just here but I went to
Qatar for the World Cup had the same
thing there a lot of people coming up
about because John Ronaldo obviously but
also a lot of people coming up about you
and they were almost exclusively men
young men who genuinely see you as a
role model as somebody who inspires them
as somebody they want to be like yeah so
it made me think the first interview you
had was quite combative the second time
a short interview less so I want to try
and work out in this one who you are
because it struck me as extraordinary
that Google this week revealed some
stats for the year the number one person
whose name followed people Google
searching who is in 2022 was Andrew Tate
yeah that's quite remarkable I think
there's a whole swath of the population
especially young men that feel
disenfranchised they feel
disenfranchised with the media machine
and the things they're supposed to
believe they don't feel an affinity with
the Educational Systems or the culture
and they look at a person like me who
stands up and says to things that many
young men think I haven't put a magic
spell on the world the fact that people
like what I say means that they agree
with me deep inside they may be afraid
to say it themselves but I am seen as a
Bastion of free speech and a basking
Bastion from masculinity as a whole
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about do you think you're a
Force for good or are you a force in
evolution
where perhaps you've done unsaid stuff
you shouldn't have done and as you get
older perhaps as you get bigger more
followed around the world you sense a
responsibility perhaps you didn't have
early on well we all evolve every human
evolves day by day you wouldn't be human
if you didn't evolve on an hour-by-hour
basis but I do not think I'm a Force for
good I absolutely not really know I am a
Force for good because I'm a force for
truth and truth is a good thing without
truth we're going to end up in absolute
tyranny in slavery and we're already on
our way there I feel like we're starting
to combat it my cancellation was the
beginning of a change in public
Consciousness Elon having Twitter is
another beginning of the change in
public Consciousness and anybody who
stands up and speaks what they truly
believe even if it's something I don't
personally agree with I think that truth
is absolutely important and people's
personal truths and people's personal
opinions even on differing sides of the
same opinion should be heard
tell me about your life you were born to
a mixed race uh couple your father was
an African-American a chess player yeah
uh and your mother she was from this
country correct yeah so my father was
was black chess player he was in the Air
Force he met my mother here in England
and then I was raised initially in the
United States and then I moved to Luton
England when I was younger so I've moved
around a lot I've lived uh eclectic life
in many different scenarios we've moved
around I've done a lot of different
things learned a lot of different
experiences and uh are you I mean would
you identify I consider myself British
now but I will say that part of me the
Patriotic Britain side of me is
devastated by the state of the UK
currently and I want to make that very
clear the Patriotic Britain me truly
loves this country and seeing what's
happening to it especially to our major
cities is almost heartbreaking to watch
in real time in what way it's falling
apart this is a failed Society by every
metric you can possibly measure it is
absolutely not really failing the cost
of living crisis the crime rates
everything is falling apart if you
compare it to a country tree like the
United Arab Emirates you compare it to a
city like Dubai London which should be
the greatest city on earth is failing in
absolutely every metric because our
leadership is a joke if you look at
Dubai in the UAE the leadership there is
so Flawless so genuinely genius they saw
ahead and have built almost a Utopia and
then you look at London you came and
walk around with a watch on it's
disgusting you know it's very
interesting I was in Qatar for the World
Cup obviously a lot of people in England
taking a very sensorious moral view
about the World Cup being in the Middle
East at all because of their laws
against homosexuality because of their
treatment of Migrant workers I've got to
say not that I don't share the concerns
about those things of course I do but I
found a lot of The Virtue signaling and
I think that's what it was in many cases
about the whole region actually quite
distasteful because when I was in Qatar
a I thought the World Cup was
fantastically well run an incredibly
good experience but a lot of qataris
were saying to me you know there's this
weird quaint feeling back in your
country that we all want to Aspire to
behave like that that we all want to
live in a country with massive drug
problems with massive knife crime issues
with scenes like the European
championships final where it's complete
lawlessness going on
um where
stuff like the NHS the system of
healthcare is basically collapsing where
the education system is dropping behind
so on and so on and so on it's a really
interesting perspective they were like I
know you all think that we want to have
your form of democracy in your form of
life but actually we're fine thanks
absolutely because it's a failed society
and it's Godless I think it's disgusting
we leave our old people to rot in old
people's homes and then we sit there and
say we don't have enough money for
nurses I understand this nurse strike
very well on how frustrating it can be
if you walk into a hospital and the
nurse is not prepared to work but the
nurses would be prepared to work at the
current wage if they believe this
country was spending its money prudently
when you see this country spending its
money and just absolutely wasting it
pulling out of thin air to fund proxy
wars God knows where that has nothing to
do with them of course as a nurse you're
going to stand up and say well can I get
a pay rise this country has failed on
every metric and especially our major
cities I've just come to London now I
made it very clear to my private jet
pilot I said fuel the Jet and leave it
running because the second finished
talking appears I'm leaving this
assessment it's disgusting this country
and London as a whole 10 years ago was
the one of the most hospitable cities on
Earth now you cannot walk around safely
with a watch on and you're a full-grown
man you're a full-grown adult when's the
last time there's been a serious problem
in your life that you completely ignored
and it fixed itself never ever what are
any of our politicians doing to fix any
of the problems
is planning to run again with a third
term of offices mayor all I can say is I
just everyone I know who's had any
experience of crime at any level in
London in the last few years has had a
bad experience of it of the way it's
been handled you know I mean I can give
an example I can reveal this now I've
talked for 18 months I've got a specific
death threat on one of my son's
Instagram pages in public a public
comment and it was very specific about
what this person was going to do I
couldn't use the police to evade him we
we know where you live we're going to
come and kill you and then the second
one threatening uh my son and his mother
my ex-wife I called in the police I'm
not having them putting death threats on
my sons I called the police police
investigated this they arrested somebody
over a year ago and then I heard from
the police this week that despite 18
months of Investigation of a publicly
posted comment on Instagram threatening
to kill me uh on my son's Instagram that
they will not be able to pursue the case
now I thought imagine I'm high profile
this was a front page of the Sun
newspaper if that same man called a
transgender person the wrong pronouns he
would be in trouble right so doesn't it
just show Absolutely how absolutely
asinine and banal our legal system has
become that would never happen in a
country like you never United Arab
Emirates the place I'm now residing in
Dubai where the leadership has common
sense and I'm saying that all the
leadership structures doesn't matter if
it's labor or conservative across all of
it in this nation of completely he
failed Sadiq Khan is a loser because
when you have a city which is losing
which London is is losing and all very
in all metrics across its competitive
cities around the world and you're in
charge of it by extension you're a loser
I will tell you right now instead of
virtue signaling and giving Qatar a hard
time over their religious beliefs what
we should be doing is a treaty with
Qatar to build a prison deep in the
desert give me make me mayor of London
we'll make a prison deep in the desert
and if you're caught with a knife or
robbing someone you can go do 25 years
with one meal a day in the in the
scorching sun and then what we'll do is
we'll put cameras there and we'll
interview you once a week and broadcast
that out to the nation and see if you
change your mind and make people
understand that this is a country that
should be respected and our law should
be respected instead what happens what a
Sadiq or any of the people in charge of
this country actually done to fix any of
our issues besides sit around and talk
nothing none of them have done anything
but they seem Ultra concerned with
finding money for proxy wars Ultra
concerned with rainbow Flags in another
country that is uninterested in them and
their priorities are completely messed
up of course the ambulance people are of
course the ambulance drivers are
striking of course the nurses are
striking nobody cares about the most
important things in this nation it's a
failing country in real time and that's
why I've left what about the specific
allegation by the way I don't disagree
with a lot of that um because I do think
this country is in big trouble and I do
think that one of the problems is people
think if they do have a crime against
them nobody cares anymore I know I know
nobody cares I can I have specific
examples and people who I know
personally absolutely and utterly nobody
cares I was in Heritage yesterday and
someone tried to Rob someone's watch in
the middle of the store I walk around
with six full growth I have a security
team of six full-grown men plus me and
my brother eight military age males all
over 110 kilos big men just so I can
walk around this city it's absolutely
unacceptable
what about the issue of race and I
mentioned that in the context of the
Harry and Megan ongoing debate their war
with the royal family war against the
monarchy their specific uh constant uh
referencing to the fact that they
believe they were driven out of here
because of racism in Britain what do you
make of that debate that that's absolute
fallacy and you're from a mixed race
correct background yourself correct I'm
from a mixed race background myself and
while we're discussing the leaders of
the UK although I do think they're doing
a terrible job it's kind of hard for
Megan to say that the UK is a racist
country when the leader of the UK is
darker skinned than her and the mayor of
London is darker skinned than her and I
am a person who's probably darker
skinned than her and I've never
experienced any kind of bigotry against
myself besides the fact I'm a straight
male I'll get bigotry for that before
I'll get bigotry for my skin color I
think it's just a cop out in her not
wanting to be perspicacious and
self-reflective enough to understand
that she has attacked an age-old
institution and there are people who are
very patriotic about that institution
and by attacking it and bringing a
degree of distaste to it don't like her
and if you're a dislikable person you
can't just instantly stand up and say
it's because of my skin color it might
because be because of your actions and
some of the things you've said I mean I
think there's probably no doubt she said
racism on social media because who
hasn't it's a successful you probably
have well as I said to sell I've had
death threats on social media no no one
seemed to care very much um but I I
think that's probably inarguable my
issue with what they've both been doing
is if you're going to make allegations
against an institutions like they're all
family and the monarchy you've got to
actually provide some evidence you can't
just spray gun this thing out there and
say well somebody was racist yeah and
airing dirty laundry is never going to
be respected by the populace and being a
tattletale is never going to be
respected by the populace and I think
the problem with the modern world we're
living in is a lot of age-old traditions
are being destroyed in real time it
doesn't matter what the tradition is
most of them are being eroded and
something like the British royal family
which has been around for a very long
time is an age-old tradition one of the
things holding the UK together one of
the last things we have to sit and
detriment it and to sit and insult it
and to give way secrets from inside of
it and try and paint a negative image of
it is going to upset a lot of people and
you have to be prepared for that
backlash you can't say I've done things
to upset people but it's nothing to do
with what I've done it's purely because
of my skin color also it's kind of
ironic that she's doing that because
she's not particularly dark skinned it's
kind of funny to sit her sit here sick I
mean
I think the truth is I don't know what
look you can say that I can't
um the reality of it is I just don't
know what the specifics of the racism
she says she's had because we've not
seen any evidence the universe is a
funny Place Pierce if you're looking for
something you're going to find it right
when I got canceled when they attacked
me unfairly lied about me across the
entire mainstream media deleted me from
social media so I couldn't defend myself
and lied about me repeatedly I could
have stood up and said it's because I'm
Brown I didn't do that I sat and said
okay there's people who misunderstand my
message my message is is a positive one
people misunderstand me let me
self-reflect and understand that yes
perhaps this said a long time ago was
said in the wrong way perhaps this was
understood perhaps people don't
understand this I could have just copped
out and could have just been refusing to
self-reflect on any level and said it's
because I'm Brown that's why they did it
but that's not the immature way to be as
an adult what did you think of the
Jeremy Clarkson Fury where he wrote well
I think most people but including him
belatedly after he'd published it and
written the column he did make an
analogy from A Game of Thrones uh scene
which most people I think did find
across the line and was deeply offensive
I I think you've crossed a line what do
you think yeah I understand why people
feel that but when you attack an
institution as old as the British royal
family you're attacking patriotism in
and of itself for one of the
most respected countries or previously
most respected countries on Earth and
you're going to have some visceral
reactions perhaps Jeremy Clarkson is too
famous and too well renowned to say
those kind of things but there's a lot
of people who genuinely feel that way
and that's why he said it and this is
what happens when you attack age-old
institutions on any country should he
ever apologize that's a good question it
looks like he did personally I think as
a man you should stand up say what you
mean mean what you say I don't think you
should ever apologize for anything
you've ever said even me what if you say
something truly then if it's very
offensive and you actually do regret it
if you truly regret it then yeah okay
you can apologize but if at the time you
meant it then the best thing you can do
is say look I have just changed my mind
I no longer feel that way but at the
time that's how I felt and I'm the
person who says what he feels and that's
what I felt at the time and I apologize
that offended you